Este vídeo ha sido posible gracias a Masterworks.
Querida comunidad, hace poco tiempo, aquí en
VisualPolitik, publicamos nuestro particular
ranking con algunas de las ciudades más peligrosas
del mundo. Algo que siempre resulta complicado y
que nos obligó a escoger entre muchos candidatos
que quizás injustamente se quedaron fuera.
¡Qué os voy a contar! Solo México hubiera
necesitado para ser justos un vídeo entero.
Y al norte de su frontera también son
muchas las ciudades que merecen nuestra
atención. En aquel vídeo mencionamos a San
Luis - una ciudad de la que por cierto ya
hemos hablado aquí en VisualPolitik - pero
también podríamos haberle hecho hueco en el
ranking a ciudades como Memphis, Detroit,
Chicago o quizás y sobre todo Baltimore.
Pero claro, ¡cómo íbamos a dedicarle a Baltimore
tan solo un minuto cuándo una de las mejores
series le dedicó 5 temporadas completas!
Por supuesto estamos hablando de The Wire.
Seguro, seguro que muchos ya la habéis
visto. Y los que no, tomad nota porque
merece la pena. La cuestión es que el último
capítulo de esta serie data del año 2008. Y
desde entonces han pasado muchas cosas. Tantas
como para llegar a montar una nueva producción:
(El creador de 'The Wire' regresa a Baltimore
para la nueva serie de HBO 'We Own This City')
Amigos, amigas, al igual que está pasando en
el conjunto de Estados Unidos, la violencia se
ha disparado en Baltimore. Solo en 2021 se
registraron 338 homicidios. En Nueva York,
por ejemplo, hubo 485. La diferencia
es que Nueva York tiene 15 veces más
habitantes que Baltimore, que no
llega a los 600.000 habitantes.
Estamos hablando de una ciudad que en los años
50 llegó a rondar el millón de habitantes. Pero
claro, entre los que mueren y los que se largan
de Baltimore, no paran de perder población.
Lo peor es que las malas noticias no acaban
ahí: cada vez hay más casas abandonadas,
más drogas en las calles y menos
futuro para sus jóvenes. Por eso,
la pregunta es: ¿Estamos acaso hablando
de la ciudad más decadente y violenta
de los Estados Unidos? ¿Qué están haciendo
las autoridades de Baltimore para cambiar
la situación? Y lo que resulta aún más
importante: ¿Están consiguiendo algo?
Hoy en VisualPolitik vamos a
dar respuesta a estas preguntas,
pero antes vamos a ver un poco de Historia.
Pero antes de pasar a la historia, dejadme
que os hable un poco de Masterworks.
¿Sabías que el mercado del arte está valorado en
casi 2 billones de dólares y que Deloitte estima
que pueda crecer casi otro billón más para 2026?
Seguro que estás pensando: a mí que me cuentas,
no tengo suelto en mi cartera como para
comprarme un cuadro de Picasso ahora mismo.
Pues ojo, espera, porque Masterworks permite a
personas de cualquier parte del mundo acceder a
un mercado hasta hace muy poco inaccesible
para el común de los mortales: el arte.
¿Pero es rentable el arte contemporáneo? Bueno,
pues este mercado consiguió mejores datos
que el propio SP 500 incluyendo dividendos.
Apreciándose un nada desdeñable 164%
en los últimos años, de 1995 a 2021.
El proceso funciona así:
El equipo de análisis de Masterworks
estudia miles de datos para encontrar
obras financieramente atractivas
con potencial de revalorización.
Luego, las compran por importes que van
desde el millón de dólares hasta los
30 millones y las titularizan mandando
una oferta pública a través de la SEC.
Por último, conservan la obra entre
3 y 10 años hasta que se vende.
Si quieres echarle un vistazo a Masterworks
por ti mismo, te dejamos un link con el que
te puedes saltar la lista de espera y crear
una cuenta directamente sin coste alguno.
Y, como siempre a la hora de invertir: mucho
cuidado, no existe nada libre de riesgos.
(THE WIRE)
¿Estáis buscando casa? Pues…
Estáis de suerte. Con apenas
20.000 dólares podéis compraros
una en pleno Baltimore. Eso sí,
mucho ojo porque vuestro sueño americano podría
tornarse en pesadilla en cualquier momento.
Las casas adosadas de ladrillo del siglo XIX
que tanto abundan en el oeste de la ciudad
ofrecen en la actualidad un panorama
desolador. Muchas están abandonadas.
En su día fueron el hogar soñado por miles de
inmigrantes europeos que llegaron a Baltimore
durante su rápido crecimiento industrial de
finales del siglo XIX y principios del XX.
Una época en la que la ciudad más grande del
estado de Maryland llegó a ser uno de los
lugares más prósperos de Estados Unidos gracias a
sus fábricas, su producción de acero y su puerto.
(En el año 1950 Baltimore era la sexta ciudad
más grande de los Estados Unidos. Sin embargo,
un tercio de sus habitantes emigró a medida
que sus industrias navieras y
siderúrgicas fueron cerrando.
Luego, la crisis de Baltimore se agravó aún
más en los años 70 y 80 cuando la heroína,
la cocaína y el crack comenzaron a
circular en abundancia por sus calles.
De esta forma, la adicción a las drogas
se extendió por los barrios más pobres
del oeste de la ciudad, donde las leyes
raciales y unas políticas de vivienda
claramente racistas habían concentrado
a la población afroamericana, la cual,
por cierto, supone alrededor de dos
tercios de todos los habitantes.)
El declive de Baltimore durante las últimas
décadas es evidente. A pesar de haber sido
una de las grandes plazas de Estados Unidos
y de contar con activos tan valiosos como la
prestigiosa Universidad Johns Hopkins, su
comercio portuario y zonas tan atractivas
como Fell 's Point, lo cierto es que
los problemas no dejan de multiplicarse.
En los años 90 otras grandes urbes
estadounidenses como Nueva York tuvieron
éxito en su lucha contra el crimen gracias
a una combinación de prosperidad económica,
un consumo más reducido de alcohol
y una mayor presión policial.
Mientras tanto, Baltimore se hundió
cada vez más yw e más. Las cifras son
la prueba del algodón. Y aquí señalan
que una octava parte de la población
de Baltimore es adicta a los narcóticos y
que la ciudad tiene la tasa de enfermedades
venéreas más alta del país así como una
de las más altas en cuanto a homicidios.
(Desde 1990 Baltimore ha perdido más
de 75.000 empleos industriales que
no han logrado ser compensados con
otras actividades. En consecuencia,
una parte importante de sus habitantes
han quedado atrapados en la pobreza.
En los barrios más deprimidos de
esta ciudad, más de la mitad de
los adultos están desempleados y la mitad de los
adolescentes faltan habitualmente a la escuela.
Para que os hagáis una idea, un estudio
realizado por sociólogos de la Universidad
Johns Hopkins concluyó que sólo el
4% de los niños de las zonas más
deprimidas de Baltimore consigue
terminar la universidad.¡El 4%!)
Son datos terribles que suponen un enorme
mazazo para los programas sociales impulsados
por el Partido Demócrata. Y que visto lo
visto no han servido prácticamente de nada.
Los políticos demócratas han controlado
la alcaldía de Baltimore desde 1967.
Hablamos de 55 años de gobierno que
han ido de fracaso en fracaso en la
que una ciudad fue conocida como
Charm City, la Ciudad Encanto.
A comienzos de siglo, por ejemplo,
muchas esperanzas se depositaron en
el alcalde Martin O’Malley, un joven
abogado de ascendencia irlandesa.
Prometió reducir la desigualdad y limpiar
las calles con una política de "tolerancia
cero". Instó a la policía a detener a los
jóvenes que actuaran de manera sospechosa
y registrarlos en busca de armas o drogas. Y
claro, la policía se tomó al pie de la letra
lo de la tolerancia cero: puso en su punto
de mira a los que cumplieran dos requisitos:
ser jóvenes y negros. Como podéis imaginaros,
un perfil que abunda en Baltimore.
¿Y sabéis qué? Se les fue de las manos.
(Solo en 2005 la policía de Baltimore realizó
100.000 arrestos. Recordad que hablamos de una
ciudad de apenas unos 600.000 habitantes. Como
este ritmo de detenciones era completamente
insostenible, O’Malley tuvo que dar marcha atrás
en su enfoque policial de mano dura. Pera el daño
ya estaba hecho: el plan destruyó la confianza
en la policía de buena parte de la ciudad.)
El resultado fue un clima
perfecto para las pandillas,
la violencia y los crímenes de todo tipo. Así
que los que han tenido oportunidad no lo han
dudado. Han salido corriendo de allí.
Unos 16.000 edificios están designados
oficialmente como vacíos pero el número
real podría ser el doble. Calles enteras
de casas están tapiadas. Tan solo en los
últimos 6 años se han demolido 5.000 casas.
Para colmo, la credibilidad de las instituciones
también ha hecho aguas. Desde el año 2010,
dos alcaldesas han renunciado al estar
involucradas en escándalos de corrupción.
Para que os hagáis una idea, en los últimos 12
años Baltimore ha tenido 6 alcaldes diferentes
y otros tantos comisarios políticos. Un
auténtico desastre, que por supuesto,
no ha pasado desapercibido. Fijaos lo que en
2019 el propio Presidente dijo de esta ciudad.
(Trump ataca a otro legislador afroamericano
y llama a Baltimore un "desastre repugnante,
infestado de ratas y roedores")
Lo peor es que los políticos demócratas
no tuvieron con que rebatirle. Baltimore
se ha convertido en lo más parecido
a un supermercado de la droga. Y si
las cosas ya estaban mal, desde
el 2015 se han puesto aún peor.
Atentos.
(WE OWN THIS CITY )
Todos sabéis quien es George Floyd. Pero
debéis saber que antes de George Floyd,
estuvo Freddie Gray y otros tantos que
han sido víctimas de lo que podríamos
tildar como violencia racial de algunos
agentes de la policía en Estados Unidos.
El caso es que en 2015, Freddio Gray, de 25
años, que había sido detenido por portar una
navaja falleció mientras estaba bajo custodia de
la policía de Baltimore como consecuencia de las
lesiones que sufrió en su columna mientras
era trasladado en una camioneta policial.
Al parecer era una práctica habitual de la
Policía de Baltimore esposar a los detenidos,
no protegerles con el cinturón de
seguridad y conducir bruscamente
para que fueran lo más parecido a una pelota
en un maletero, golpeándose por todos lados.
El caso es que las protestas masivas y
los disturbios se extendieron por toda
la ciudad. Fue algo así como un punto
de no retorno. A raíz de este suceso
los disturbios aumentaron un 50%. Y ahora
podemos encontrarnos con noticias como esta:
(Baltimore supera los 300 homicidios
por séptimo año consecutivo)
Ahora bien, un momento. Baltimore es
una ciudad donde de vez en cuando la
policía mata a algún negro. Pero sobre
todo es una ciudad donde prácticamente
todos los días un joven negro es
asesinado por otro joven negro.
Algo de lo que por cierto, son muchos,
incluida una investigación del propio gobierno
federal, los que culpan a la propia policía.
(El prejuicio racial es generalizado entre la
policía de Baltimore, señala
el Departamento de Justicia)
¿Cómo va un cuerpo de policía
a garantizar la seguridad si
nadie confía en él? Si la mayoría
de los habitantes de una ciudad
lo ven como una institución hostil
y se niegan a colaborar con ella.
Esto es un problema. Los episodios
de brutalidad policial hacen mucho
más improbable que los residentes
de los vecindarios negros acudan
a la Policía para denunciar delitos
y cooperar con las investigaciones.
Y la misma desconfianza se extiende sobre
los órganos judiciales, muy relacionados,
lógicamente con la propia policía.
Y eso no es todo. Para colmo, una parte del
cuerpo de policía se dedicó durante años a
extorsionar a personas inocentes y a robar a
traficantes de droga para quedarse con su negocio.
Digamos que se creyeron los amos de la ciudad.
(“Haciendo Justicia” La ciudad de Baltimore
paga 525.000 dólares a una víctima
que dice que policías corruptos lo
enviaron a prisión por error; es uno más
de los 14 millones de dólares en acuerdos)
Al final la crisis económica,
la pérdida de empleos,
los narcóticos y la corrupción de
la política alimentaron el desastre.
Pero, esperad un momento, porque aún hay más.
Hoy día la violencia se ve alimentada
por un enemigo que va más allá de las
fronteras de Baltimore. Hablamos del fentanilo,
un opiáceo sintético muy potente
que ha sustituido a la heroína.
Es una locura. Tan sólo en 2021, más de 100.000,
¡cien mil personas! fallecieron
en Estados Unidos por sobredosis.
La situación es tan grave que su último discurso
sobre el estado de la unión, el propio presidente
Biden hizo de esto toda una prioridad nacional.
El caso es que en 2007 las sobredosis de opiáceos
se cobraron la vida de 256 habitantes de
Baltimore, en su mayor parte por culpa de
la heroína. Para 2018, ese número se había más
que triplicado a 814 muertes por el fentanilo.
Baltimore tiene la tasa de mortalidad por
opiáceos más alta de todas las ciudades
estadounidenses. Y ahora tiene un plan para
reducirla. Otra cosa es que el plan sea bueno.
Atentos.
T3(ADICTOS A LAS DROGAS… Y A LOS IMPUESTOS)
El alcalde de Baltimore, Brandon
Scott, del Partido Demócrata,
quiere enfrentarse a este boom
de sobredosis abriendo sitios de
consumo seguro. Se trata de lugares donde
las personas acuden a consumir narcóticos.
Allí están bajo la supervisión
de personal médico que puede
intervenir de forma rápida en caso de
sobredosis para evitarles la muerte.
Imaginaos lo mal que están las cosas para
que estos planes se pongan sobre la mesa.
No es una idea original. Pero si es una idea
que topó recientemente con la oposición de
la Administración Trump, que tumbó en
los tribunales federales una propuesta
similar de la ciudad de Filadelfia. Las leyes
vigentes a nivel federal en Estados Unidos
señalan que no están permitidos los sitios
públicos abiertos para el consumo de drogas.
Pero ahora las cosas podrían cambiar con Biden.
(El Departamento de Justicia señala que
puede permitir sitios de inyección seguros)
Los miembros del Partido Demócrata
que defienden estos lugares esgrimen
que tratar de salvar la vida de
estas personas está por encima
de cualquier otra consideración. Las
buenas intenciones no se cuestionan.
Pero ¿de verdad que lo mejor que se puede hacer
por las personas adictas es abrir un lugar al que
pueden acudir a meterse de todo o casi todo?
Una pregunta difícil y cuánto menos polémica.
Y sobre todo no parece que pueda contribuir
a mejorar las cosas en Baltimore.
Hablando de futuro. Fijaos en esta noticia.
(Un estudio encuentra que una familia de Baltimore
con ingresos promedio paga el 14,1% de sus
ingresos anuales en impuestos locales y estatales)
Esto supone que en Baltimore pagan
un 50% más de impuestos locales que
la media de las grandes ciudades de
Estados Unidos. Esta ciudad, amigos,
tiene un régimen fiscal con una progresividad
muy agresiva. Y en total la ciudad ocupa
el cuarto puesto entre las grandes urbes
estadounidenses con la carga fiscal más elevada.
Algo así como el sueño dorado de muchos
demócratas de ala de Berni Sanders.
Esta elevada carga fiscal tiene
una explicación. Como habéis visto,
la ciudad viene perdiendo población
desde 1950. Entonces, ¿qué han hecho
los políticos del Partido Demócrata
que gestionan Baltimore desde 1967?
Ni más ni menos que subir los impuestos para
tratar de mantener los ingresos de la
ciudad ante la fuga de contribuyentes.
Así que a un problema generalizado de violencia,
narcóticos y falta de oportunidades laborales se
suma el tener los impuestos más altos del país.
Y la pregunta es, ¿Quién en su sano juicio va
a querer mudarse a Baltimore? ¿Qué negocio
puede prosperar en semejantes circunstancias?
Por supuesto, los altos impuestos expulsan a más
profesionales y reducen la renta de las familias,
lo dificulta que las empresas crezcan.
Esto reduce la oferta de empleo y agrava
el problema con la violencia y los narcóticos.
Es algo así como una espiral destructiva.
Y sí, seguro que alguno de vosotros
está pensando, pero Alberto,
¡Habrá que sostener los servicios
públicos! Pues, ¿sabéis qué? Fijaos.
Algunas investigaciones apuntan a que el 77%
de los estudiantes de secundaria en Baltimore
tienen la capacidad y la comprensión
lectora propia de la escuela primaria.
Un desastre total.
La cuestión es: ¿Quién demonios va a
querer mudarse a Baltimore? Amigos, amigas,
esta ciudad tiene que darle al botón de reset
y empezar prácticamente desde cero. No estaría
mal que en ese camino copiaran las políticas
económicas de estados como Texas o Florida.
Si las cosas no cambian la que una vez fue una de
las grandes ciudades del país terminará
en escombros. Si algo está claro es que
el plan demócrata en Baltimore no
ha funcionado absolutamente nada.
Pero dicho esto, turno para ti: ¿Qué solución
pondrías sobre la mesa para arreglar los
problemas de esta ciudad? Dejadnos por aquí
abajo vuestras comentarios y abramos debate.
Ahora si este vídeo os ha parecido interesante
no olvidéis darle a like y
suscribiros a VisualPolitik.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.